el agua es el líquido de la vida la
bebemos nos bañamos en ella cultivamos
cocinamos y limpiamos con él las
moléculas más abundantes de nuestro
cuerpo de hecho todas las formas de vida
que conocemos morirían sin eta pero lo
más importante es que sin agua no
tendríamos de helado un helado
porque flotan estos cubitos de hielo si
fueran cubitos de argón sólido en un
vaso de algún líquido se hundirían y
ocurre lo mismo con muchas otras
sustancias pero el agua sólida es decir
el hielo es de alguna manera menos densa
que el agua líquida
como es posible ya sabes que cada
molécula de agua está compuesta por dos
átomos de hidrógeno unidos a un átomo de
oxígeno veamos unas cuantas moléculas en
una gota de agua con una temperatura de
25 grados celsius las moléculas se
doblan estiran giran y se mueven por el
espacio ahora bajemos la temperatura lo
cual disminuirá la cantidad de energía
cinética que tiene cada una de esas
moléculas por lo que se doblarán se
tirarán girarán y se moverán menos lo
que significa que en promedio ocuparán
menos espacio ahora pensarías que cuando
el agua líquida empieza en congelarse
las moléculas simplemente se juntarían
cada vez más cerca pero eso no es lo que
ocurre el agua tiene un tipo especial de
interacción entre sus moléculas que
muchas otras sustancias no tienen y se
llama enlace de hidrógeno
ahora recuerdas que en un enlace
convalesciente se comparten dos
electrones normalmente de manera
desigual entre los átomos es un enlace
de hidrógeno un átomo de hidrógeno se
comparte también de forma desigual entre
átomos un enlace de hidrógeno se ve así
dos se ven así estos son tres
10 y 4 y 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 y bueno y
podría seguir en una sola gota de agua
los enlaces de hidrógeno forman extensas
cadenas entre cientos miles millones
billones trillones de moléculas y estos
enlaces están rompiéndose y reformándose
constantemente ahora volvamos al agua
cuando se van enfriarlo por encima de
cuatro grados celsius la energía
cinética de las moléculas de agua
mantienen interacciones breves entre sí
los enlaces de hidrógeno se juntan y se
rompen como las relaciones en la escuela
secundaria es decir rápidamente pero por
debajo de los cuatro grados la energía
cinética de las moléculas de agua
empieza a decaer por debajo de la
energía de los enlaces de hidrógeno por
tanto los enlaces de hidrógeno se forman
con mucha más frecuencia de la que se
rompen y unas bellas estructuras se
empiezan a emerger del caos fíjate que
la ordenada estructura hexagonal es
menos densa que la estructura
desordenada del agua líquida y ya sabes
que si un objeto es menos denso que el
líquido en el que se encuentra el objeto
flotar a por eso el hielo flota en el
agua
y que más bien consideremos un mundo
donde el hielo no flote la parte más
fría del océano sería su oscuro suelo y
una vez que estuviera congelado siempre
estaría congelado olvídate de comer
langosta ya que los crustáceos perderían
su hábitat o del sushi que harían los
niños canadienses en el invierno sin
estanques helados para jugar hockey o
para pescar y olvídate del oscar que
ganó james cameron porque el titanic
habría llegado a su destino despídete de
los blancos casquetes polares reflejando
la luz solar que de otra forma freír y
ha en el planeta
de hecho olvidan los océanos tal y como
los conocemos
pero lo peor de todo es que uno habría
té helado
de lado